we are learning more now about the
reality that in the craziness of last
week Iran shot down a passenger airplane
killing everybody on board this was a
Boeing 737 leaving Iran for Kiev a
Ukrainian airline the evidence was
growing and growing
even though Iranian officials were
denying it it became undeniable and over
the weekend the officials in Iran for
the first time admitted that yes they
shot down a Ukrainian jet airplane
killing the hundred and seventy-six
people that were on the plane this does
a few things aside from being an
unspeakable tragedy including seriously
hurting the credibility of those same
Iranian officials who were insisting day
after day last week that they had
nothing to do with it
when it was increasingly clear that they
did numerous questions about the
airplane being shot down one why wasn't
Iran's airport closed an airspace shut
down during last week's hostilities and
the missile launches we don't have an
answer there now The Associated Press
reports that general Amir Ali Hajis adei
the head of the guards the Iranian
guards aerospace division says his unit
accepts full responsibility for the
shoot down there was an address
broadcast by state television where he
said when he learned the plane had been
taken down quote I wished I was dead he
said that the Airlines pilot and crew
did nothing wrong that an officer made
the bad decision to open fire on the
plane after mistaking it for a cruise
missile the Iranian supreme leader the
Ayatollah expressed his deep sympathy to
the families of the victims said that
the Armed Forces should quote pursue
probable shortcomings and guilt in the
painful incident but the Iranian people
are furious as they should be very
quickly protests against the
establishment Islamic theocracy of Iran
have broken out in Tehran of course it
was not just Iranians who died on that
plane it's not any better or worse
depending on who dies but it was 82
Iranian 's 57 Canadians 11 Ukrainians
and many others Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau has been very involved in
publicly speaking about this in so many
Canadians
were on that plane now there's a
conversation happening about is this
partially Donald Trump's fault and the
reasoning is well Iran shot down the
plane while they were retaliating to the
United States his assassination of Kasim
soleimani so if Trump hadn't
assassinated Soleimani Iran wouldn't
have been firing missiles and all of
these people would now be alive you know
in a strict narrow scope that that is
technically true in other words what
caused Iran to be firing the missiles
was that Trump ordered Soleimani killed
and you can argue that Iran retaliating
was less optional than Trump deciding to
go and assassinate Kasim soleimani in
geopolitics this is a pretty dubious way
of thinking about things
Trump can then say well the only reason
we killed Kasim soleimani
was because Obama instead of going after
Soleimani signed a terrible Iran nuclear
deal terrible according to Trump by the
way and then we would say no no no that
didn't force you to assassinate
soleimani and Trump askance a well
Iran didn't have to respond with the
missiles that they did or they should
have been more competent they should
have better trained the people that were
using the missiles they should have
fired them at different locations from
different locations they should have
cleared the airspace so for me this is
not so much about trying to figure out
what degree of blame does Trump have for
the shooting down of the plane again you
could say well what about the Iranian
Revolution that took place in the late
1970s that really caused everything that
happened in the last 40 years that led
to Trump even wanting to assassinate
Soleimani it's not all the same right
the Iranian Revolution as a general
cause of today's status quo is not the
same as Trump personally saying let's
kill soleimani which leads to Iran
firing these missiles that take down a
jet aircraft but the point is this type
of accusation is rarely useful in
figuring out what needs to happen next
it's used mostly to score political
points for one side or for the other if
everything had been the same but Iranian
forces were
trained at distinguishing a passenger
plane from something else this wouldn't
have happened not to mention that this
regime has been lying about what
happened as well the head of Iran's
aviation organization said that the
plane definitely wasn't hit by a missile
just days ago and of course it was and
they continued to lie until they could
lie no more so Trump gets plenty of
blame for many things he's done here
the assassination ripping up the Iran
nuclear deal for no reason without Iran
having violated it but to make the focus
of the plane being shot down as tragic
and unnecessary as it was to say that
that was because of Trump's decision
specifically is at minimum unproductive
I don't think it's the place where we
should be focusing our energy and now we
have protests in Iran and we will see
what comes of them that is where our
energy should be focused and the fact
that Iranians who are known to be
increasingly progressive as a population
fighting back publicly publicly
protesting this Islamic theocracy that
is in place in Iran that is what we
should be focusing on do you feel like
you just don't have enough time to
become as intellectually well-rounded as
you would like to be that there are just
not enough hours in your week for you to
read all of the books that you want to
read one of our sponsors is called
blinka stand it's an app that lets you
consume an entire non-fiction book in 15
minutes it's only about eight bucks a
month but you can try it for free for a
week and get 25% off a subscription when
you go to blankest comm slash Pakman
what blinka studs is take thousands of
popular non-fiction books and condense
them into either text or audio that you
can read or listen to in just 15 minutes
and what you get is all of the most
important ideas and information from the
book imagine being able to listen to an
entire nonfiction book in the amount of
time it takes you to drive or walk home
from work I just finished listening to
the way we eat now by bee Wilson whose
work I've recommended to you before
super interesting look at how the global
food system works and impacts the way
that we live
blink is has totally transformed how I
consume information I love it of course
I read a book in its entirety
when I can but there are simply just so
many books that I want to read and would
not have the time for if it weren't for
blinka stay they have books on politics
economics philosophy science you name it
you can try it out yourself totally free
for a week and get 25% off if you decide
to subscribe just by going to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video like the
rest of us I bet you're going into 20/20
thinking about what you didn't get
around to in 2019 and your goals for the
new year if you want to work towards
being your best self in 2020 understand
more about the world around you and make
sure that your time is well spent then
blink astiz for you